all right uh on this Wednesday morning
we're hearing a second vote to impeach
the Department of Homeland Security
secretary my orcus could come perhaps
next week after House Republicans missed
it by two votes last night in a dramatic
fashion you saw it here on Fox our next
guest was one of just four Republicans
who voted against it here to explain his
vote a republican from the great state
of California Congressman Tom mlto Tom
good morning to you good morning okay
everybody's coming up to you Tom why'd
you do that
well for the same reasons I oppose the
Sham impeachments of Donald Trump uh the
Constitution reserves impeachment for
treason bribery or other high crimes or
misdemeanors that is a very specific
meaning crimes relating to the office uh
uh my orcus is guilty of
maladministration on a truly Cosmic
scale but that that is not grounds for
impeachment we know that because the
Constitutional Convention considered
that and rejected it for that very
reason and the moment we dumb down that
standard uh Democrats take control of
the house they'll turn it against the
conservatives on the Supreme Court
they'll turn it against a future
Republican Administration this is a road
we really shouldn't be going down and
then the final point is this even in the
fantasy world where the Senate by a
two-thirds vote would remove him from
office he would simply be replaced by
somebody like okazu Cortez this is not
going to be solved by replacing one
leftist official with another it can
only be solved by replacing the entire
admin ministration and that can only be
done by the people at The Ballot Box so
your problem you got a problem with the
way he's been running the department but
then again he's just taking instructions
Tom from the home office and the home
office is the White House and that's Joe
Biden oh exactly which is why removing
him wouldn't change anything frankly
removing Biden for Camala Harris
wouldn't change anything it's the
administration itself and its policy so
the problem you know I tell folks all
the time you want to know how this
happened if you voted for Biden and the
Democrats this is exactly what you voted
for and if you're surprised by that you
weren't paying any attention because
this is what they promised to do this is
what they've done and this is what
they've defended for the last three
years the American people I think are
coming around to that conclusion I think
there's a lot of buyers remorse from
Biden voters uh uh looking at what that
has now uh done to our country uh why
would we want to get in the way of that
uh by by politicizing this in in in a
very unconstitutional way right so uh
the move to impeach my orcus failed and
then they brought extraordinarily after
that loss they the speaker went ahead
and brought up essentially a clean bill
for uh a little north of 17.5 billion
dollar aid for Israel and I know you
voted for that but this this is one of
those things where uh it was voted down
because you needed uh a super majority
but the Optics ultimately just look bad
that the house is divided over helping
Israel because that's what it looks like
now yes I I I I agree and that's a
tragedy and I don't think that's the the
the actual statement of the sentiments
of Congress I know there were some
conservatives who who wanted to see a
pay for but the beauty of a single
subject Bill like the one that went
before the house it offers precise
Clarity this was strictly overh helping
Israel and I think anyone who brought
other issues into it uh whether they
were fiscal or of course on the
Democratic side you have a large element
that's promas of uh you're you're you're
you're confusing the issue
Tom before we go uh there are a lot of
Republicans who are esteemed at the
house leadership uh from your chair
representing a district in southern in
in Southern California uh does speaker
Johnson have your confidence does he
know what he's doing because it looked
like yesterday was just a huge
humiliation for the Republicans well I
think it was a huge mistake of uh to
allow eight members of our conference to
override the conference and join with
the Democrats to remove Uh Kevin
McCarthy
um uh he he was the one person in our
conference uh who was able to do that
job with a razor thin majority um and
and and and that's that that was a
self-inflicted wound of immense
proportion all right Tom and Kint real
pleasure talking to you sir thank you
very pleas do you need a food tester now
on Capitol Hill uh no no I just eat out
of the vending machines okay like
everybody else all right Tom thank you
very much thanks I'm Steve duy I'm Brian
kilme and I'm me aart and click here to
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube page
to catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling
analysis